all the way what's going on everybody
hey I'm John good to be here this is
bambam the dog thank you for having
thank you it's a real honor to be here
with you guys today thank you I love you
too
right on this is awesome
[Applause]
so many people Wow
thank you are you got the hi MA
such a such a big stage makes me nervous
I'll do my best to speaking English
we are making a new kind of
action-adventure game it's Turkey but
not the survival horror game that we are
known for in the game you will meet
spirits some dangerous and survivors
that each have their stories you will
need to ask yourself it is normal or
paranormal I asked myself this question
every time I go to the office just
kidding just kidding just feeling we are
very excited let's take a look
thank you but before we dig into the
next game there is someone I'd like to
introduce first what what are you doing
here wait wait wait wait wait a minute
there's been a bit of a mix-up you're
not the right Bowser sorry but I'm the
right Bowser for this presentation Hey
[Music]
not this way
no no this way Oh bye-bye
maybe next time ah just look at that
funny [ __ ] goat and allow me to
introduce you to the deadliest of the
love this is not out she's experienced
waves of buffets samurai we have a city
to burn
[Music]
please welcome Keanu Reeves
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
how's it going
yeah all right
good to see you thank you all right all
right I gotta talk to you about
something I mean talking about something
[Applause]
CD Projekt RED cyberpunk 2077 okay let
me tell you the feeling of of being
there of walking the streets of the
future is really going to be
breathtaking breathtaking
alright alright alright so I guess I
gotta finish this so tell me do you guys
want to know when there's one of the
release date yeah all right then check
this out
[Applause]